hi i'm reza aslan and i'm rayne wilson
and today we're talking about our
genders
are genders do you how many genders do
you have i have a penis oh
is that a gender though you know what i
i actually don't even know at this point
anymore
[Music]
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
[Music]
when my twins were in
pre-kindergarten so it wasn't even
kindergarten so i guess they were you
know four years old maybe four to five
years old
uh one of the kids in their class
um
you know decided to just start living as
a as a girl instead of a boy
and
uh i remember there was you know so many
conversations and debates about it among
the parents and the faculty we're
talking about los angeles here too so
we're talking about you know
people who are just primed for for you
know these kinds of progressive ideas
and you know we're having these parent
meetings where it's like well is the kid
making
uh their own decision or is this
something the parents are forcing upon
them if the parents were very clear
about the fact that you know this is
just something that that
they the kid kept bringing up over and
over again and it's just sort of which
they just let
this kid live the way you know they
wanted to live
and then i remember
the kids in in the class
it was like nothing had happened at all
it was just like well yesterday was
wednesday and today was thursday
yesterday it was a boy today is a girl
what's the big deal yeah what's
everybody talking about i remember once
i accidentally used the wrong pronoun to
refer to the kid and and without missing
a beat my boys were like you mean she
bubba
it's she not he and i was like oh sorry
which makes me think
that
maybe gender
isn't as
an internal of a thing as we think it is
that maybe
it is
merely a construct maybe it's something
that that is defined by your society
right it's so easy for kids to just be
like well duh
of course yeah this he's now a girl
so if kids can be so
accepting and fluid and
aware
so effortlessly why can't we why do we
struggle with it so much in our society
what would it look like for instance to
just eliminate gender entirely you know
we're talking to somebody today who
believes in that very idea not just
this idea of eliminating you know gender
binaries in order to make people more
comfortable in their own skin and be
able to define themselves but the idea
that in eliminating
the concept of gender as this you know
clear-cut
socially defined binary
that in eliminating gender
we are bringing freedom and liberation
not just to people who may or may not
themselves
uh think of themselves in you know
as non-binary or non-conformist when it
comes to gender but to all of us even
those of us who do think of ourselves
purely in terms of male or female that
that if we just
rid ourselves of of the the handcuffs of
this social construct called gender that
we will all
be liberated from
uh the expectations that are put upon us
by
society
their name is alok vade menon and they
are a writer performance artist fashion
designer and model that's a lot of
things that's a lot of things their work
pushes back against the idea of binaries
and categories and we are very excited
to have them on the show today
[Music]
here's where we wanted to start so
i am a what you would call a cisgendered
white
middle-aged suburban dad dude 53 years
old
and
now
things are i don't want to say
fracturing because that almost has a
negative connotation but
branching out in so many
kind of mysterious ways to someone uh
like me so can you
kind of walk me down that path a little
bit can i just say i love the fact that
you you made that question sound
theoretical like pretend i'm just a
stupid white old guy hypothetically just
pretend like hypothetically
so i think what's most interesting about
what you were saying is your use of the
word now and i think that's a great
launch pad for this conversation is a
lot of this and especially the way that
i enter this conversation has to do with
history and time
that actually we keep on pretending that
this gender and sexual revolution is
something new but it's actually
something very old and what is new is
the idea that you would be identifying
as a straight man because the idea of
straightness and the idea of man are
more recent historically than the idea
of gender non-conformity so actually
what most people don't know is that
almost every indigenous society across
the world
recognized genders outside of a western
binary and recognized that gender was
malleable and fluid and that we lost
those traditions and histories
with the sort of spread of a european
colonial understanding of a binary
gender system
and then even among that
the idea of like heterosexuality is a
recent cultural phenomenon and then most
societies in the world you didn't
actually orient an entire identity
around your sexual preference right
so
i think that what we're seeing is not
necessarily something new it's a
reclamation of what always was perhaps
we're using new language but we're
hearkening to a time that was
systematically policed you've done a lot
of work really kind of thinking about
this can you can you take us a little
bit slower through that history totally
um so a lot a lot of people don't know
is that one of the tactics of
colonization and especially british
colonization was the criminalization of
lgbtq people so i'll speak for example
here about the history of south asia
which i'm most familiar with so the
british basically came in and they had a
lot of fomo fear of missing out because
my ancestors were all like polyamorous
non-monogamous queer gender fluid and
having a really great time and they were
kind of anxious and insecure
so they criminalized same-sex activity
with section 377 which just got repealed
one year ago right
which they saw that
sex was essentially quote unquote
against the order of nature
and then two they also criminalized
cross-dressing with something called the
unique ordinances law and what this did
basically was arrest and incarcerate
people
for
publicly cross-dressing in public
and they actually pursued an entire
administrative agenda to completely
eliminate gender variant people from all
of south asia which complicates a lot of
our understandings of colonialism in
south asia because a lot of people say
oh they weren't trying to commit
genocide but they kind of were against
gender variant people and this is
actually echoed across the world
happened here in what is now called the
united states as well there's often
gender non-conforming indigenous people
who were first targeted and murdered by
by european colonists and a lot of what
i'm trying to think through in my work
philosophically intellectually
politically
is why
like why were they so pressed with how
amazing and fabulous and ornate and
powerful we were what had to be
extinguished and then i think it's most
interesting to think about that word
nature right because the irony of nature
is that we pretend like things we use
the word natural to say that nothing was
orchestrated it's just organic
but who gets to speak for nature is a
political practice
and what so much of what
white european people did and continue
to do is get to control who gets to
speak for nature so they will make a
series of political decisions and
choices and then be like it's natural
when it actually wasn't natural it was a
series of political decisions and
choices
and i think that in order for man and
woman to be made as the only natural
ways to be you had to erase and
invisibilize literally disappear
anything that contradicted the existence
of man and woman and we see the legacy
of that today in the united states right
with the ongoing murders of trans and
gender non-conforming people this year
there have been almost 20 murders of
trans people in the united states alone
and by the time that this interview is
released i'm sure that there will
probably be more that we're living in an
epidemic of some of the most
profound anti-trans legislation being
introduced and debated at the local and
state level that is essentially trying
to bar us from existing in public it's
not just about bathrooms it's our right
to exist from public but this is an
age-old project of trying to disappear
us so that they can claim that
heterosexuality is natural and that the
gender binary is natural but they're not
natural they're actually fragile because
if they were natural they wouldn't
require constantly trying to disappear
everything else in order to be real
wow well well said i mean
there's some research that we have here
about for instance uh gender identity
and native american traditions and
there's obviously hundreds of native
american traditions among the
tens or hundreds of thousands of
indigenous traditions all around the
world but this uh looking at this term
the two spirit um
which was this idea that
certain
certain people were born with an
embodiment of two genders residing
within one person
um that's fascinating and in the
cherokee language there's 10 different
pronouns
um all of which are gender neutral but
so there's no way there's tons of way to
say we but there's no way to say he
in the cherokee language and i'm
wondering if you have other examples
because you're talking from the
historical context of gender of
indigenous um
definitions of gender and fluidity and
sexuality yeah there's just so many
across the world there's the mushay in
mexico m-u-x-e there's hijras kothis
arvani's in india
there's kathuys in southeast asia
there's just so many of these
identities that have just been lost and
are being extinguished um and i think
that's why for me it gets frustrating
when you see the mainstream conversation
about this and it's always dismissed as
we're just post-modern snowflakes who
read a lot of college textbooks and now
are like making up language and genders
i'm like actually that's not true this
has been around for hundreds of years
and when you say that you're you're con
you're contributing to that erasure of
those people
and i think it's really important when
we
uh acknowledge two spirit people right
that those two spirit people were also
seen as spiritual leaders in their
community
and i think that's a crucial component
that also gets lost is it's not just
that these
communities have and continue to
acknowledge but also that they affirmed
recognized and respected
and that homophobia and transphobia were
actually imported and imposed on so many
people across the world you know you
said uh it goes back hundreds of years
actually it goes back thousands of years
right i mean in in the torah um there is
this sort of notion of the the the
jewish legal tradition
um identifies at at least six distinct
genders right yeah
as kind of an ancient way of recognizing
gender as being
more fluid and less sort of bifurcated
but going back to something that you
said earlier about the the way in which
colonialists have so often
used issues of gender conformity as a
means of control it reminds me of
you know something that i just saw not
that long ago uh eric erickson the sort
of right-wing pundit just tweeted uh
today
there's no such thing as a gay penguin
to me this sort of
intense rage and fear embedded in that
tweet says so much about the way that
people respond to these kinds of
questions what's the fear all about like
i get the religious stuff fine but it's
not all religion there's this kind of
visceral fear about ideas of gender
non-conformity what what do you think
that's all about a look i think my my
artistic practice is a meditation on
that very question because i am really
trying to figure out why something as
seemingly insignificant as me wearing a
dress
walking down the street can solicit
so much like we're talking in new york
city which is supposed to be one of the
most progressive places in the world
people laughing at me taking photos of
me pointing at me spitting on me
physically and sexually assaulting me
simply for existing in public right
it it it's just ridiculous how
especially especially under this
political administration there's been so
much effort to criminalize and demean
the trans community when we're such a
seemingly small community right
but i think that's where the fear is
maybe we're not as small as they make us
out to be
and what i've sort of started to realize
and and i think i wanted to say this
earlier rain when you were when you were
describing yourself is
i think in a world where we were
encouraged to explore our identity and a
world in which there were many options
and we weren't coerced into having to be
in this box or that box there would be a
lot more gender non-conformity those
people might still say that they're men
or women but men and women wouldn't look
like what we've been taught men and
women have been look like so i read all
of this fear as a panic that maybe there
are more of these people than that than
there than there are visible right now
and i think that when it comes to gender
and sexuality so many
straight cis people are coming are are
becoming confronted with the fact that
maybe their straightness and their
cisness is not as universal and not as
natural and that calls them to question
so much in their life that they've been
taught and i think that there's an
element of violence there that's really
important and when i was preparing for
this conversation with you all i really
wanted to make this point
the irony is that a lot of people think
that people like me are selfish because
we're only fighting for like a small
insignificant group of people but i'm
actually fighting for every single
person in the world because a world
without the gender binary actually will
help men so much
because there would no longer be the
pressure of having to prove your
masculinity or your manhood and so i
think that what happens is especially
when cis men hear this they're like wait
i didn't have to go through that ritual
of violence like there's another way to
live and when people have become so
conditioned into violence they mistake
freedom as a threat
milkshakers do you identify as crypto
curious
if you've thought about entering the
world of cryptocurrency but felt a
little overwhelmed coinbase makes
learning to buy and sell simple
cryptocurrency might feel like a secret
or exclusive club but coinbase believes
that everyone everywhere should be able
to get in the door whether you've been
trading for years or just getting
started coinbase can help and if you've
been looking to level up your financial
portfolio it's always good to diversify
why not think about cryptocurrency
backed by the world's leading investors
coinbase keeps your portfolio safe and
secure while adding crypto into your mix
it's a trusted easy to use platform to
buy sell and spend cryptocurrency they
support the most popular digital
currencies on the market and make them
accessible to everyone they offer
portfolio management and protection
learning resources a mobile app you can
trade securely and monitor all your
crypto all in one place
millions of people in over a hundred
countries trust coinbase with their
digital assets for a limited time new
users can get ten dollars in free
bitcoin when you sign up today at
coinbase.com milkshake
sign up at
coinbase.com milkshake for 10
in free bitcoin this offer is for a
limited time only so be sure to sign up
today that's coinbase.com
milkshake so i've been starting pretty
much every morning now with my athletic
greens like i wake up i love like my
athletic greens yep it's changed
everything i've got
more energy my you know immune system is
stronger and it actually tastes good
like that's the crazy thing about it it
tastes fantastic one delicious scoop of
athletic greens and you're absorbing 75
high quality vitamins and minerals whole
foods source superfoods probiotics
adaptogens to help you start your day
right i get up in the morning most
mornings i have a smoothie instead of
like an actual breakfast protein
smoothie i add the athletic greens and i
can i can taste it's got a nice zing to
it it's a little bit lemony it's crisp
and i definitely feel
increased energy
and focus yeah and it's lifestyle
friendly it doesn't matter if you're
like keto or paleo or vegan or dairy fee
or gluten free it contains less than one
gram of sugar no gmos no nasty chemicals
no artificial anything really right now
it's time to reclaim your health and arm
your immune system with convenient daily
nutrition especially heading uh into the
flu and cold season it's just one scoop
and a cup of water every day that's it
no need for a million different pills
and supplements to look out for your
health to make it easy athletic greens
is going to give you a free
one year supply of immune supporting
vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase all you have to
do is visit athleticgreens.com
milkshake again that is
athleticgreens.com
milkshake to take ownership over your
health and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance
in a way maybe what it is is that those
people who are already feeling somewhat
kind of unmoored and and out of place
and having a hard time figuring out
uh who they are and maybe retreating to
some of these more primal forms of their
identity that those people perhaps
have sort of one assumption that they
can hold on to which is i'm a man and
that's a woman and that's you know
that's where the dividing line it stops
and now we're saying well no actually no
it's not that that even that is is up
for grabs and i think maybe that's where
some of this kind of
fear comes from right that it's what
you're describing is people who are
who are angry who are upset who maybe uh
respond with hatred
but
i mean maybe i'm wrong look you tell me
but what i notice the the the the
primary emotion that i see as a response
to these conversations is fear
100 but it's fear that masquerades as
other things often i see this as a
spiritual imperative for me it's not
about to be a woke like conscious person
you should act like this i'm saying to
be a good person you should act like
this and when i say good person what i'm
actually subscribing to is like my
vision of the world that i want and i
think that so much of what we're doing
as a trans movement is about world
visioning we're actually saying we
demand the right to self-birth we demand
the right to self-author we demand the
right to celebrate creativity and not
conformity and these gestures are so
impossible in a world that is ritualized
conformity and categorization you were
raised in a hindu faith tradition how
did growing up
shape your view of gender through that
spiritual tradition
you know it's it's a very sad story of
like
the problem with colonialism is that it
makes the people that it affects even
more colonized than the people who came
in to begin with and i think you're
really seeing that right now with
contemporary indian community especially
contemporary indian diaspora where
people are just hyper nationalist and
hyper religious and hyper conservative
so i'm still the only queer
indian person from my town that's come
out and
a lot of people are like wow everyone
must be so proud of you like you're
doing all these things i'm like nope
they just don't even they don't even
invite my family to things they just
like don't even speak about it and it's
just very sad because i now know
so many things that i was not exposed to
at temple about the history of hinduism
about the history of gender fluidity in
south asia
but these things were selectively edited
out to create this kind of recuperative
masculinist model of religion and we're
seeing this across religious traditions
and faiths right is that there have
always been queer and trans people who
are foundational to every contemporary
religion but their contributions have
been underemphasized if not erased and
queer people have been cut out of the
religious and the spiritual which is one
of the biggest paradoxes to me because
queer and trans people were at the
inception of the spiritual and and for
me
the the language of transition is such a
spiritual language like it's it's
literally like
i am embarking on this quest and this
journey yeah that a lot of people are
not going to validate that a lot of
people i'm in fact going to lose so much
that the the consequences of what i'm
doing could cost me my life but i'm
still doing it and not only am i going
to do it i'm going to practice this as a
daily practice meaning every day i make
a choice of do i want to live life easy
and just go outside in like gym shorts
or do i want to be me and go out and a
flaming red lipstick and i make that
choice because i believe in world making
and i believe in creating a world where
someone could see me some person who
doesn't even think that someone like me
is possible and then they will never
forget that image and then they can
become that like what is more spiritual
than that when we learn about all of
these disciples across the world that's
exactly what they were doing but i think
this is what's so terrifying and sad
about this moment right now is similar
to how the rhetoric of nature is being
manipulated the rhetoric of science is
being manipulated and the rhetoric of
religion is being manipulated coming
back
to this
this internal thing right this idea that
maybe
the reason that this is such a fraught
conversation
may be that it so often leads to
violence and anger and and hatred and
death has to do with the fact that
deep down inside us
we know
that it's not as black and white
and
i don't know maybe culture religion has
has kind of convinced us to kind of tap
that down and then when we see someone
who throws that off
right
who says
no these are terms that have no meaning
and i am going to
live
you know uh sort of liberated from the
shackles expressing my real life yeah
identity yeah that
it makes people
feel like that little part of them that
isn't sure
is being exposed to the light and the
only way to deal with it is to scream at
the top of your lungs there's no such
thing as a gay penguin
as loud as you can
am i just am i making any sense alok i
don't know 100 i totally agree with you
and i i i honestly
think that that is our power as gender
non-conforming people i reframe it like
the only way that i can survive like the
the torrential hate that i receive
online offline is i remember that these
are love letters by another genre
that these are people who who don't
understand even what's going on in them
because they've been dispossessed of the
language and the history to even do that
so i have a deep amount of mercy where
i'm just like you know circumstances
have made it such that i actually am
free and you are not and i'm sorry about
that and i'm sorry that you've been fear
that you've been made to fear the very
things that have the potential to set
you free and i know now that it's not on
me it's totally on them
and i think that realization for me was
so liberating because i i was carrying
this burden of other people's
projections for so long in my life and
then i was like you know what like
actually all the things that they're
teaching me to hate about myself are
precisely the things that i love about
myself no and so when someone spits on
you on the streets of new york yeah your
ability to look at them not only forgive
them but have the deepest compassion for
for them because they are stuck
whereas you are
free
right that's a that's a spiritual act
that is a right that's a christian like
act totally i call it compassionate
militancy and
i really challenge myself and my
communities on this because i just do
not believe that it is radical or even
progressive to
respond to systems of violence using the
same grammar of those systems of
violence we need to create a new
language and that's why i'm a poet
because i believe poetry is the creation
of new language and when we create new
language we create new action we create
new action we create new worlds and so
what i try to do is to respond to things
in a different in a different sense like
in a completely different constellation
of what meaning is
and so i i
i just don't i understand the impulse to
say
these people are homophobic and
transphobic but i'm like isn't that
doing the same violence we reduce people
to one category and identity what i'm
saying is these people are traumatized
and hurt these people are repressed and
scared how can we create a form of
freedom that is so frothing and so
delightful and so wonderful that they
will recognize that this is not the
thing that they should be fearing it's
the very thing that they should be
embracing and and that is to say i think
that there are people who identify as
men and women who are embracing this and
i think that's an important
clarification is i'm not saying that
every single person needs to identify as
non-binary tomorrow and like join me on
the streets wearing a skirt but what i'm
saying is you need to interrogate why
you're uncomfortable of the people who
are doing that and get to a place in
your life where you're not uncomfortable
where that's just another person
navigating this fleshy mess of being a
body and existing in this country at
this time
what does it look like to have a world
where we eliminate the concept of gender
sure i think it looks like a world in
which we appreciate the infinite
complexity of one another a world in
which we recognize that there's such a
profound singularity to each person and
that any kind of essential category
that we lump people into will actually
obfuscate more than it illuminates i
think it looks like actually being able
to experience people
for
their total personhood and not just the
arbitrary and arcane stereotypes and
what that looks like in a tangible sense
is when i meet people i don't think are
they a man or woman i don't think oh
they're being nice 4a insert i
experience them as a person you know and
it's just very funny to me that like in
the conversation around race in this
country so many people are willing to
like just move on to this like we're all
one race i don't see color be it i don't
see colors but i definitely see penis
and
exactly
exactly and like why aren't you taking
that energy to the way that we have
about gender what is it about gender
where people need to reinscribe and when
i'm saying people i'm also being
critical here of feminism because
feminism has also had a very fraught
relationship with trans people because
feminism in a lot of ways has been about
restabilizing the binary of saying women
deserve equality with men but what we're
seeing as a movement is why should we
have to be men or women to begin with
and that i think what i want to
challenge is why when a baby is born is
the first question people asking is it a
boy or a girl and not is your baby okay
or how can i pay for their college
tuition or like
are you gonna be able to afford rent
like these are the more practical
questions to be asking what is it that
makes gender relevant is that we
continually make it relevant so let's
not make it relevant let's not talk
about it let's not bring it up let's
actually find ways to take gender off of
our identity documents let's stop gender
segregating institutions if we fear
violence let's address violence not just
make this like a sort of ruse let's
actually confront a culture of violence
and toxicity and not just pretend that
gender is this amorphous thing that's
concealing it let's actually re-educate
and recalibrate our arcane stereotypes
about man and woman i mean the agenda
could go on for so long
and i just i i i think i i would love to
ask you this question as well it's like
there's that component of fear but
why is it that people when presented
with the world like a liberated and free
and just and happy world are so
resistant to it like that's i think a
spiritual question for me it's like time
and time again you have so many people
who are like okay there's a way out of
the sinking ship and people will be like
no i love the sinking ship so much like
i just want to be here drowning and
they're like okay i'm leaving and
they're like okay like what is it that
keeps people committed to drowning i i
have a i have an idea do you wanna i
mean it yeah i think look we've talked
about this a lot uh just together on
this show is that
existence
is a mystery
it's
huge and unwieldy and messy
and impossible to wrap your head around
so what do we do as human beings we try
to make sense of it by categorizing it
by simplifying it you know that's where
identity comes from you know the
difference between us and them
my color your color my country your
country my gender your gender like
it's weird to say but going by a lok's
uh you know beautiful analogy
um
we do prefer a prison cell
if the alternative
is this vast unknowable
uh you know
universe that's but that's going to fear
and control again and
and i agree and i think the solution is
god i think the solution
is god of course not god and the
gender
conforming white male with a beard
[ __ ] obviously you're talking about
with a beard are you talking about
yourself i am i'm a little bit
it's like not all white men with beards
okay god like
yes hashtag um
but
in
the um embrace of the divineness of the
universe there is an embrace of the
unknown that we are going to die that
the universe seems to go on forever no
one knows why it's here that in this
incredibly beautiful and sometimes
terrifying universe there's an
incredible amount of diversity um
there's there's skin colors and there's
gender uh identifications on every
level and there's uh all kinds of
there's exquisite and mysterious beauty
all around us unknowable and it's
unknowable
and
um and we don't know what comes after
this bod this corporal experience so
by living in the divine we're living in
an embrace of otherness and that
diversity is uh is strength diversity is
what gives humanity and creation it's
it's miraculousness
because
humanity can be diverse because the
nature is diverse and the the cosmos are
diverse so
that's the the release of fear is the
letting go of of trying to control the
mystery of of the divine so maybe the
true binary here isn't between male
female you know uh cis trans whatever
all that maybe the true binary is
between
those who revel in the question yeah and
those who desperately need the answer
right you know like is the mystery
enough for you
or
do you need an answer because there
isn't an answer you can construct one
and pretend there there is and and you
know lock yourself up and make yourself
feel better but i think in many ways
this goes back to the earlier
conversation that we were having you
know when i was saying that maybe it has
something to do with
this deep
dark place within all of us where
if we were forced to actually examine it
we may admit
you know to ourselves in a dark room
that
perhaps i'm not as confident in my
certainty over say my gender as i
pretend that i am uh
but
maybe that deep
dark
place maybe that's the soul
that you're looking into your soul and
you're realizing
huh
my soul isn't male my soul isn't female
but it's technically you know the true
me
so what do i do with that what do you
think of that eloque what do you think
of the
the the the gender of the soul if we're
if we're all spiritual beings
uh manifesting in these you know in
these meat suits for a limited amount of
time on this earth
um does the soul have a gender i don't
think so i think gender is a particular
construction of this like iteration of
history time and culture i don't think
it's a universal like
meaning or purpose i think in a lot of
ways gender is an obstacle to meaning
and purpose
um and it's something that we have to
move beyond in order to access meaning
and purpose but i i really agree with
you about the the articulation you made
about the binary between those who can
relish in the question and those who
need the answer because i i actually
have a book coming out in june about
this where i was trying to sit through a
lot of the questions we talked about
today and what i ultimately concluded is
what i've learned as an artist is that
the unknown the unknown is actually the
most prolific site of engagement for me
like if i
if i say i'm going to write a poem about
this it's going to end up being [ __ ] but
if i just start writing and then i look
at i think my definition of art is
creating something with my hands that i
don't recognize with my eyes and that's
a spiritual practice because i'm like
whoa i was just channeling something you
know and a lot of times when i'm
performing i'm just completely
ad-libbing like i just sort of move away
from script and i'm just channeling
something and for a long time i denied
that as a spiritual practice and then
now i'm like okay actually i am and
that's the closest i get to what a soul
approximates and and i think that
the the framework of a soul
for me surpasses not just gender but
language and any attempt that we have to
say even calling it a soul
encapsulates it it's for me more of
actually surrendering to that feeling
and i think that feeling in the gut is
what you're sort of returning to is like
that anxiety that fear actually
recognizing that the very things that
were uncomfortable about those are the
freedom feelings like to sit with that
profound discomfort and that just this
profound disarticulation to be open to
our disarticulation to be open to
falling apart and i i just remember that
vulnerability comes from the word vulner
which means wound and vulnerability
means willingness to be wounded and
there's something very poetic about a
wound and i don't i think that so much
of especially this iteration of culture
has been about resolving the wound
patching the wound hiding the wound but
i'm actually about let's let's be
wounded together and let's actually
theorize and think and process from a
place of woundedness and not recognize
that woundedness as a lack but actually
is an opening
[Music]
we're gonna move on to our lightning
round questions are you ready fasten
your seatbelt
when do you
feel most connected with the universe
when i'm performing
can you describe your soul in uh 10
words or less
ambivalent
what color is god
beyond our visual field of perception
when was the last time you ugly cried oh
my gosh i do that all the time so
maybe like three to two minutes ago
care to describe the circumstances
um just like being you know
just the the burden of being in the
world what's your biggest fear
that everything that i'm doing is for
naught
what is one thing you know for sure
hmm
the best
answers are questions
that's good
what is the one thing in this world that
you hate
no god there's so much
um bad fashion yeah all right
and finally what is your life's big
question
hmm
i question mark
[Laughter]
look this has been absolutely
fascinating so much for us to think
about thank you so much for joining us
thanks for having me and thanks for
inviting me on the show
[Music]
that was so fascinating was amazing
amazing so i mean
articulate and beautiful and just like i
mean again like you and i you know we're
we live in los angeles it's not like
we're not exposed to these issues but
i've never had it articulated so well
yeah and uh the spiritual reverberations
beyond gender and our
identity uh
i found especially fascinating yeah me
too and you know this this conversation
that we were like batting around about
does the soul have a gender and it's you
know it's i've never really thought
about that question or frankly
asked that question but yes let's not
forget that soul the word itself is kind
of problematic and it's a construct of
you know western ideas true true
absolutely true but
all people regardless of what language
you speak or where in the world you are
or what culture you belong in or what
religion you're from or whether you even
accept the existence of it or not all
people
when they think about the idea of soul
make a very simple distinction right
whatever the soul is it's the thing
that's not your body
yeah would you would you agree like yeah
isn't there something really instructive
there i mean if it's the thing that's
not your body well your body is the
thing with the [ __ ]
your
the ovaries or the ovaries or the vagina
or the testicles or as my four-year-old
refers to it the tentacles uh-huh the
other day he goes how many tentacles do
you have
how many tentacles do i was like what
what i don't have any tentacles and he
goes you don't have any tentacles
i think he meant testifies
um
isn't that the end i mean we're talking
about like does the soul have a gender
well if the soul has
nothing to do separate from the body the
body is the thing with the gender i mean
isn't that isn't the answer right there
i don't know
so
we're walking down the street you're
from enid oklahoma you're walking down
the streets of new york city and you see
a person who apparently looks like a man
in a dress with rainbow hair and giant
earrings and lipstick
and
you want to take a photo of this
human that you've never seen anyone
presenting that way in the world
what's what's your next step the next
step is
there's a soul
what a beautiful expression of that soul
in this
body in a you in the unique way
i'm embracing the mystery of the
universe
and i embrace the mystery of this person
who's different than i am
that's the only i know i'm sounding like
a hippie right now it might sound like a
naive hippie but i really think that's
what it's all about yeah
so
what do you think about this idea what a
world without
gender
what would what does that look like or a
world with a continuum of gender yeah
and uh
varying expressions of gender
should we follow the cherokee maybe we
need ten pronouns
we need ten pronouns me ten pronouns
send us your ideas
milkshakers as you know when you rate
and review us on apple podcasts and ask
us your life's big question you get to
come on the show and then ask that
question to us in person and today on
the show we have someone joining us here
with a really good one this is a good
question
uh elizabeth hi elizabeth hi hi rain hi
reza it is so exciting to be on this
show right now so uh what's your what's
your question elizabeth well my question
is complicated but the simplest way i
can ask it
is
if you take away
all variables of life your environment
what you're taught
at the end of the day
what
is our human nature
are we inherently going to choose good
or are we going to choose bad wow
that's really good i got to be i go back
and forth on this wow i really do
sometimes i think you know what
human beings were generally good but we
but we you know can are capable of bad
and then sometimes i'm like no we're
generally bad but we're sometimes
capable of good
right religion most religions say we're
bad right that's the whole point of
christianity yeah but that wasn't that
wasn't created till the fourth century
under augustine you know there was
original sins not really not a real
thing you can't you can reverse engineer
it into the story of adam and eve but
it's not really there it takes work it
takes work to do so that's funny that
you bring that up because that's one
thing when i asked you know people that
i've talked to about this you know
that's one thing i bring up well you
know look at cain and abel you know it's
just from the start you know no matter
how far we go back there's always
that greed or or that destruction
but even in biblical terms when it came
to cain and abel
there was a third being a god
that
made cain jealous
to cause him to kill abel so if there
wasn't
that influence to make that emotion
would there be that that sin that that
murder
that that need to
be jealous you know what i mean
if we don't have something influencing
the way we are thinking
are we just in ourselves inherently good
people will we choose to do the right
thing always if we have no preconceived
notions what do you think rain you need
your own you need your own podcast
you can do astrology and philosophy
thank you i
i will say like it
you have no idea how much your podcast
really means to me i listen to it every
week
and it is so great to hear people
talking about the things that i'm
thinking every day
and wondering is there anyone out here
thinking the same way or asking the same
questions
and if we continue to do that and find
the truth
can we as a human species
you know do the right thing for all of
us not some of us or you know a majority
of us but for everyone and everyone can
be included and and live in a utopia
amen sister i'm i'm not you this is
you're barking up my tree you're singing
up my alley you're dancing down my
unicorn i don't know what it is that's
fantastic i will say i'll throw in a
couple of thoughts on this one is
there was a recent story about a year
ago where oh i know what you're going to
say they found a real life lord of the
flies yeah yes that's right so lord of
the flies we all know william golding he
was kind of a cynical alcoholic anyway
apparently in kind of a butthole he
wrote lord of the flies and said you
know if these little school boys go on
an island they're all gonna like try and
kill each other and just go mad
and
they found an actual shipwreck of
students in the south pacific from a
boarding school
and what did they do they helped each
other they built a ship they they voted
on things they were they really stuck
together and were kind and good they
kept in touch for you know 50 years
after they sold the movie rights to this
of course and it was a real life lord of
the flies where people were good you
know and
so i i'm going to lean towards the good
because i'm always going to try and find
the positive in something because
otherwise i'm just
going to put a gun in my mouth but i
yeah but also i want to say that there's
always this kind of talk about like good
and evil and
there's definitely i would say that evil
is a weird term i they would say it's
like good i hate to say this people can
piss off a lot of people but there's
good and there's animal because evil is
just an extension of animal right if you
want to subvert yourself over someone
that's an animalistic impulse to try and
be the alpha right well you take that to
an incredible extreme and you have
tyranny let's say you know um
everyone wants to amass you know animals
want to amass acorns in the winter
cavemen wanted to amass you know
deer carcasses in the winter but if you
want to amass too much stuff then that's
greed so really i think uh evil is just
an extension of these kind of um
baser impulses that we have inside of us
so it's important to see evil as as an
unhealthy extension of something
that it was essentially natural to begin
with so here's here's my and i do go
back and forth i really do
but
i start with uh you know the sort of
first principles right which is the only
thing you really know is yourself you
know and so i think about myself and i
think am i inherently good or am i
inherently bad am i inherently a good
person
who struggles not to do bad things or am
i inherently a bad person
who struggles to do good things and if i
were to be perfectly honest with you i'd
say that i'm a good person who struggles
not to do bad things and then when i
think of other people i'm like those
people suck
they're clearly bad
right you know but but i think that most
people think of themselves the way that
i think of myself which makes me think
since all the only thing i really know
is me
that people are inherently good
um and that they struggle
not to be bad
um
so yeah i do think that people are
inherently stupid does that
count
i would definitely agree i would
definitely agree
so i guess then
is it
is it clear you know isn't it is there a
definite answer
and and really reza i i have to kind of
also go down that line with my thinking
like
maybe there is no we are this or we are
that
we just are making those decisions you
know day by day moment by moment to
choose what we want
to be and how we want to be in this
world
yep that's the the one thing that rayna
and i we've talked to a lot of people on
this podcast and we talked a lot about
this question of you know being good
and the the answer that like the people
that we trust always come back to is
being good is just doing something good
every day like just trying yeah that's
what how do you be a good person try try
okay my wife my wife always says is like
you know when things are just getting
chaotic and crazy she's like
just do the next right thing because
sometimes that's all you can do just one
moment at a time one breath at a time
one hour at a time just do the next
right thing and if more people did that
we'd have a better world we'd have this
utopia you're talking about
yes absolutely and you know not to go on
a tangent or anything but that also
brings up questions for me like
you know i i agree that i think most
people try every day to do something
good and and with our neighbors and our
community we are more likely to to be
good to each other
i think we just lose this humanity when
when we go on a bigger scale it's like
we can't
see that
and so for me
it's
it's like how do we reach those people
how how do we get people to see that
there's more than just my circle that
everything you do has a ripple effect
for everyone and choosing to do one good
thing here
can branch out and and just
don't have preconceived notions about
anyone or any situation and
you know just do the right thing even
when you're unsure or or you
you get what i'm saying 1 000 that was
elizabeth such a brilliant beautiful
question and i love thank you for being
a fan of the show and i'm glad thank you
so much oh that's so sweet and uh you
are a good person so i will say if
humanity could be a little a little bit
more like elizabeth shelton folks then
we're we'd be in good shape let's do an
episode on this question we should
way to go way to go elizabeth thank you
so much i will definitely be listening
in
all right thanks very much thank you
folks if you want to come on the show
and ask us uh your own life's big
question very very easy just rate or
review us on apple podcast or you can
contact us directly at reza aslan at
rayne wilson on both twitter and
instagram at metamilkpodcast on twitter
or at metaphysicalmilkshake on instagram
ask us your question maybe we'll have
you on like elizabeth and you might
stump us
thank you again to our guest today alok
vade menon their instagram is a place of
beautiful challenging interesting
fashion and ideas and poetry uh that's
at alok v menon that's
a-l-o-k-v-m-e-n-o-n
check it out
[Music]
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rain wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it's produced by safa
samezadeh yaz harris lane mick dimaria
hashem self and dj lubell cast media is
the production and distribution partner
it is edited by tyler newbold and audio
mixed by joshua harris original music is
composed by jeff tang it was produced by
amy estroy and rebecca lehrer of the
mash-up americans associate producers
are jocelyn gonzalez lindsey crowderwill
sarah pellegrini mary phillips sandy and
shelby sandlin
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm so woke i i haven't slept in months
that's how we'll walk like an artichoke
tone um
yeah i'm actually awake because i've
been up like all night
you're way cooler than either of us
[Music]
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you